War ples just struck the area it seems a
house was targeted during our coverage
the destruction is significant as you
can see but thankfully we were not
injured as a result of this air strike
here in central Han Yunis where a house
was hit by a missile from one of the
Israeli warplanes that are constantly
flying over the area alongside
reconnaissance aircraft
while smoke is rising as a result of the
violent air strike in central Han Unice
particularly on the albah street or shik
Ahmed Yassin Street as it's commonly
known civil defense vehicles have been
dispatched in the area which has already
been
evacuated a house was possibly targeted
as you can see here and smoke is still
buil
artillery missile and aerial strikes
continue in this area the bombardment is
almost non-stop here in central
kanun as you saw just now Israel's
bombardment goes on in central hanun
shells are falling sporadically and war
planes are targeting civilian homes in
the midst of this intense bombardment
civilians particularly those living in
the western parts of the Central
District are attempt to seek shelter as
the military operation moves forward in
central khun with every new missile
there's further damage more homes are
destroyed and additional casualties are
recorded make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer